as the mainstream media loses more and
more power they've become more and more
dangerous they employ pockets of
character assassins so-called
journalists who slander those
threatening their power and profits
usually outsiders are their targets
falsely framing them as traitors racists
and even rapists with sleazy innuendo
destroying brands and families with no
remorse
barstool sports's dave portnoy was in
the crosshairs this week one of the
nastiest publications around business
insider wrote a hit piece about portnoy
insinuating a few of his sexual
encounters crossed the line
but the writer julia black didn't
present a shred of evidence that a crime
was committed
portnoy who's not married was just
smeared as a sexual scoundrel and was
forced into doing damage control over a
seemingly questionable and manufactured
scandal and while portnoy was asking for
fair treatment business insider was
attempting to peel away bar stool
advertisers
you're looking at the anatomy of a
modern day media kill shot make no
mistake this is a kill shot aimed at
dave and bar stool sports a company he
started from scratch and now a new major
player in the media sports and betting
world
because portnoy had loyalty facts and a
platform to present them he survived the
kill shot
if anybody looked at the details of this
case the details of this article um
my reaction to it the facts of it you
would realize that there's nothing there
i got accused of rape that's my
life like that's as horrific a crime as
you can be convicted of all right and
accused of i got accused of it with so
far in eight and a half months
two sources that i was able to disprove
in three days
he laid out text messages and videos
blowing gaping holes in the hip piece
not everybody's as fortunate to be in
that position though which is why these
kinds of episodes can be so scary
let's bring in dave portnoy founder of
bar stool sports so dave what did you
learn this week about the media
you know it was actually scary i already
knew a lot of people didn't like me and
i already know there's a lot of
falsehoods and you know you always hear
the term fake news and until you're
really a victim of it or
in the crosshairs you don't realize how
bad it can get you're right i had the
ability to fight back and you know i had
the receipts i had dms that i hadn't
deleted but i'm lucky because i actually
do delete dms uh time to time and clean
my phone i just happen to have him so if
i didn't have that you know he said she
said i have nothing to prove i got lucky
that i had all the receipts and could
plead my case but
if i didn't
i'd be at the mercy of what people
thought about me it would be he said she
said it's a scary dangerous game i've
also seen the second the article is
printed with these salacious headlines
every single person who didn't like me
the blue checkmark brigade that i call
them all retweeted it dave's awful this
is what we expected i have definitively
definitively proven my innocence none of
them are attracted none of them had to
say anything they just let you out there
to die they go and they hide it's
disgusting yeah they're never gonna
issue a retraction that's not their
playbook and didn't you say that you had
contacts with this reporter her editor
and were trying to offer her information
to update the story at least what was
their reaction to that
so the way it broke down is they
contacted me eight and a half months ago
julia black and said she wanted to do a
glowing piece on me my rise in the media
in stocks uh i declined i said thanks
for the interest not interested i didn't
hear until eight and a half months from
her with all these allegations i heard
from every single girl she literally
contacted everybody i'm associated with
in social media girls i didn't even know
if somebody talked about me asking if
they dirt on me so the article was
published they withheld the police
report i believe because they had it
didn't put it in there because there is
a police report that is nonsense and
goes directly against the story of one
of the accusers they produce the report
that's how i have it it says the
opposite all these facts came out i
reached out i said hey business insider
julia black nicholas carlson uh the ceo
henry blodgett let's sit down you bring
your own cameras you can record so
nobody can edit anything bring as many
people as you want let's have a
discussion i want to ask how can this be
true if this says something totally
different they haven't said a word they
have not responded at all no response at
all since these accusations nope print
and run print and run yeah no it's a
it's a character assassination they
they're snipers they hit you and they
walk and that's their role they did that
with me one time not to the same level
blodgett this guy who's a fraudster
convicted he's not even allowed to trade
securities they were supposed to write a
nice profile about the five they cleaved
a separate article off about me calling
me a white supremacist because i used a
phrase clash of civilizations that was
just enough to just slander me as a
white supremacist
and that's how they run dave you were
different though
because nobody
can usually do this unless they have a
platform like you
like me
most people get hit like this with a ton
of bricks
and they're canceled they're done i'll
give you the last word and it's just
it's disgusting because henry blodgett
bought a newsletter called the morning
brew we just got tweets from them today
the morning brew which they tried to
delete literally saying their game plan
to stay relevant throw as many arrows
across the internet who cares if they're
accurate and maybe one will hit this is
their game plan smear make money off it
and leave everybody in wreckage and go
on to the next target well i feel like
you're going to be getting some revenge
and we'll be
paying attention to what that looks like
dave portnoy barstool sports have a
great rest of your weekend
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else